Norton:
Hi, everyone.
So welcome to the second
in the Google Web Toolkit track.
I'm Kelly Norton.
As you might imagine,
I'm a software engineer
also working
on the Google Web Toolkit.
I also have a particular
interest in browser performance
and particularly
visualizing
the performance data
in browsers.
So since GWT
was released in 2006,
there really have been
two parallel stories
that have been
forming around GWT.
One tells about using
the Java language
to build Ajax sites,
and using all the tools
that are available
to the Java
runtime language.
The second one
is about taking the effort
that you might
put into one heroic effort,
one single
Ajax application,
and actually investing
that effort
back into the tools.
So instead of getting
just, you know,
one app that pushes
the envelope
in what you can do
in the browser,
you actually begin to raise
the ceiling
in what's possible.
Now, with browsers,
performance has always been
one of those huge ceilings
that it's hard
to push through,
you know, when you start
considering applications
like the applications
we want to develop these days.
So this talk is in part
about some of the things
that we're doing
with Google Web Toolkit
to try to push through
that ceiling.
As you can imagine,
that's an effort
that deals a lot
with a lot of small
pieces of time--
measuring and looking at
a lot of small pieces of time--
milliseconds,
in fact.
But what I hope in the first
segment of this talk
is that I'll convince you
that that's an effort
that your users will notice.
So what we're actually
gonna talk about today is--
First is why worry
about performance?
This is an answer
that everyone here
probably has a good an--
is a question
that everyone here
probably has a good answer
for already,
however, I'm going to
give you my answer.
Maybe you'll like it,
maybe you'll stick with
your answer.
After that,
GWT is tools.
So we've always said
that there was a set of things
that would just be
taken care of for you.
There's a lot of tedium
in making well-performing
web apps,
and GWT tries very hard
to take the tedium out.
At least some of it.
However, while it
would be really cool
if GWT could just
do everything for you,
we don't anticipate
getting there
until, like,
GWT 1.3 or something,
so I'll actually
talk about four things
that you should
do yourself
to help your apps
perform better.
So let's jump right in.
Why worry
about performance?
Okay, so I'll tell you,
I have a bias,
but I think it is true.
The main reason you need
to worry about performance
is it's
a usability concern.
When developers
talk about--
developers talk
about performance--
When you start
talking about users,
you're actually
talking about delay.
Well, it turns out that
we've been studying delays--
how humans react
to delays in computers
since, like, the 1960s,
and we even like
some numbers
that we've had since
the 1980s.
And so I'm gonna share
three of these numbers
that I think are really key
as you develop your own apps.
So I call this a simple model
for how delay affects us.
The first one,
which is my favorite,
is 100 milliseconds.
So 100 milliseconds
is the time required
to get a screen updated
so the user sees it
as instantaneous.
Now, I'll show you
an example in a minute
where 100 milliseconds
is not even enough.
In fact, 100 milliseconds
is the limit.
All these numbers I'm gonna
show you are upper limits.
So 100 milliseconds
is the limit
at which you update
a screen
and people see it
as instantaneous.
This is actually highly
relevant
if you're doing animations,
or if you're doing
direct manipulation techniques
like drag and drop.
Now the second number
is one second.
So at one second,
a user notices a pause.
However, there's still
a nice cause and effect
relationship.
They click on something,
and something happens.
It's still
the same single task.
A lot of people say
this is the limit
at which you should
consider giving feedback.
If you're gonna have
something that's gonna
take longer than
one second to update,
you should consider
an extra device
for giving feedback
in your applications.
And then the final
number here is ten seconds.
So ten seconds is sort of
a disruptive time.
And of course these
are all average numbers.
I mean, some people
may abandon quickly,
some people may
stay around all day.
It varies by individual
and a lot of other factors.
But this is a point
at which
disruption can start
to occur.
And, you know,
people go do other things
like issue some more
complaints
about the Facebook design.
But beyond that,
I mean,
we know that users notice.
We know that they notice
delays in user interfaces.
I mean, and the people
in this room
have probably,
in their experience,
described something
as just being sluggish--
perhaps you used a more
sophisticated word like "janky."
But you can notice.
You noticed when things
weren't responding
the way you expected it to.
The real irony in this
is the whole reason
we're doing these
Ajax applications
is we aim to give users
more control.
And it's funny that
we would then take them away
by adding different
delays like updating--
like running a bunch
of JavaScript code,
and, you know,
not returning quickly enough.
But in fact it goes beyond
just noticing
that things are sluggish.
In fact, there have
been some studies
that show that when you add
latency into the mix,
people actually start
to evaluate the content
as being lower quality.
And if you're interested in
the full details of that study,
there's a link
at the bottom,
and I think the slides
will be available.
Pretty sure they will.
Okay, so--
But, you know, don't just
trust my judgment,
let's actually try
a little experiment here.
So very simple
interaction here.
Something you've surely
seen in a Web app,
just a simple
hover highlight, right?
So I'm gonna take this,
and we're gonna try it
with no delay.
And clearly
it's keeping up, right?
I mean, it's no
problem here.
So let's actually
throw in 25 milliseconds.
Now at 25 milliseconds
it's still keeping up.
I mean, maybe if you have
the eyes of an eagle
you can discern
some delay.
But at 50 milliseconds--
Now remember I said the limit
here is 100 milliseconds,
but at 50 milliseconds
you start to see
that we're not quite
keeping up.
At 100 milliseconds,
I don't care what kind of night
you had,
this isn't keeping up.
So it just goes to show you
that, you know,
even with these numbers,
you look at the maxes,
there are still interactions
that happen in Web apps
that are very common,
in fact,
for which even
100 milliseconds
is not fast enough.
Okay, so hopefully that was
a really quick way--
if you weren't convinced
that performance is important,
hopefully that was a little bit
of a way to convince you.
Now, let's talk about
four things GWT does for you
performance-wise.
So the first thing,
we've always said
GWT produces fast
JavaScript code.
A lot of people,
when they heard that GWT was
a compiler,
they assumed that
it just did
a straight, loyal translation
from Java to the closest
JavaScript code out there.
That couldn't be
further from the truth.
The GWT compiler is, in fact,
an optimizing compiler,
and I'll tell you
some of the--
just a few techniques it does
in just a minute.
What you actually see on
the screen
are some benchmarks--
the results
from some benchmarks.
These are--
We actually took
some of the SunSpider tests,
which are benchmarks
you find
in the Web kit rendering
engine
for their JavaScript engine,
we ported over to Java.
The reason why we did this
is because the only way
to really improve
performance-wise
is to measure things.
And so we decided that,
well, if we're gonna actually
make the claim
that GWT can produce
faster JavaScript code
than you would write by hand,
we should probably
actually check this.
And continue
to check this,
and as we make changes
we should continue to make sure
that it continues
to hold on its promise.
And as you can see,
it does pretty well here
on its promise
with the ones
I've highlighted.
And I'll show you
some more in just a second.
So GWT is in yellow.
The bar in blue
is actually
the hand-written JavaScript
taken directly
out of the test
and then run
through an obfuscator
just to sort of
do apples to apples.
And you see
we do quite well.
However, we don't
win 'em all.
I mean, we--
In fact, the access-binary-trees
benchmark
revealed an opportunity.
I mean, this is
the whole reason
why we were doing
the benchmarks in general.
It revealed
an opportunity to speed up
the way we translate
Java constructors
in JavaScript.
But the great thing,
and one thing I'll try
to continue to remind you,
is that GWT is
a set of tools.
So this is now an issue
in our issue checker.
It should be fixed
by GWT 2.0,
and a speedup
is just a compile away.
So as we get faster,
your apps get faster.
So how do we do that?
Well,
it's funny because
I actually steal
this quote from online.
We cheat,
and we're quite proud of
the fact that we cheat.
We cheat on the user's behalf,
in fact.
One of the things
we do--
and I'll just talk
about three things here,
three techniques
that the GWT compiler uses
that we get
a lot of bang for,
particularly
in these benchmarks.
The first one
is inlining.
So that's just
simply a technique
where you take
a method body and you just
move it into all the places
where it's called,
the call sites.
Here's a really
simple example.
It should be pretty
self-explanatory
what this code does--
you create a new circle.
I read Josh Bloch's talk,
so he recommended
that I declare this as the
interface on the left-hand side.
I do that.
The GWT compiler sees,
but yeah,
you told me it was
a shape,
but in fact it's
a circle.
I know that.
Given the fact that I know
that it's now a circle,
I actually know
the implementation for area.
And so you see
in the last line
it actually saw,
well, the implementation
for area,
I'll just put that
in there.
And in fact, this other
method call widget.setText
I'll go ahead
and inline that as well,
and you can tell
that this is actually
an indication
for the Mozilla browser.
'Cause I think as Bruce
highlighted in his talk,
we compile specifically
for the user agent.
So it inlines
both of these.
Now it's cool because these
calls have now been sped up.
In some cases,
considerably.
But the other big thing
is the methods get text and--
sorry, the methods
"get area" and "set text"
have been
completely eliminated.
No need to even
put 'em in the source.
We don't need 'em anymore.
The other big thing
that we got a big bang for
is a technique
called string interning,
which is just
a long way of saying
we take all the strings
in your application,
we remove all
the duplicates,
we put 'em in
a global table.
The reason why
this one is important
is because there are
certain JavaScript engines
that have garbage collector
implementations
that weren't really
intended for
the apps we're writing,
notably Internet Explorer.
Now when you do
an inline function
inside of a JavaScript--
sorry, you do
an inline string load
alongside
a JavaScript function,
it actually causes
extra objects to get created,
which in turn tends
to wake up the beast,
which is
the garbage collector,
which slows down
your runtime performance.
So just by doing
this trick alone,
we get a really nice
speed-up in J-Script,
Internet Explorer's
engine,
and it helps on other
engines as well.
Now the last technique
gets the award
as the fanciest-sounding
one.
There are a number
of words for it,
but I tend to call it
method de-virtualization.
It sounds really
complicated,
but basically what it is
is I take an instance method,
I see that,
in this particular case,
because I'm writing here
against an interface,
and when you're writing
against an interface, I mean,
usually that would
be a runtime dispatch.
So you go, ah, well,
it's an interface,
and this interface
has this method getText,
so at runtime I actually
have to look and see,
oh, well,
the getText method
for this particular subclass
is here and I'll call that.
Well, it turns out
that since GWT
does this whole
program optimization,
we actually see
all the subclasses,
so in a lot of cases
we actually know
at compile time
that's actually the method
you're gonna call,
which eliminates all this need
for runtime dispatch,
and in turn we go,
eh, might as well
not even make it
an instance method
'cause when you translate
these things to JavaScript,
the way you do this
virtual dispatch
is that you assign objects
on the prototype chain,
which means that at runtime
it has to walk a list
looking for the method
that it needs to dispatch to.
No need to do it.
We already know what method
it's gonna dispatch to.
So we basically translate it
to a static method.
Now once we translate
to a static method,
and one of
the other big things
you get out of method
de-virtualization
is it just unlocks more
opportunities for inlining.
And in fact, in this case,
I've stopped short of where
the GWT compiler would.
When it got to
the JavaScript level,
it would've just easily
inlined the body of this method
everywhere it was called.
I mean, it's short,
and it's been--
particularly when you
obfuscate the names here.
Okay, second thing we do.
So in GWT 1.4,
we introduced this notion
of image bundles,
which was a really
cool concept.
It basically meant
that in your app
you could declare all the images
that you were gonna use,
all the images you're gonna
use for button faces,
all the images
you're gonna use
for just any of
the treatment in the UI,
and what the GWT compiler
would do is it would--
when it actually
ran the compile,
it would see
all the images and resources,
pick them up, and distill it
into a single image.
The reason
it did this is because
one of the number one rules
for speeding up
your app load time
is just to simply reduce
the number of http requests.
So if you can take all these
tiny, little images
in an application,
assemble them into one image,
you could actually get
a considerable speed-up.
And we really
like that technique.
In fact, we actually did
a heuristic bin packing
to try to even get the image
down a little bit smaller.
And we really
like that technique.
The only things
we didn't like
was the fact that
we still had all this CSS.
And when you have CSS,
it always has these
little images inside of it,
and these are
extra http requests.
So we decided for GWT 2.0
to generalize this
even further,
and so we've
come up with this
more general notion
on this client bundle.
And you can tell by this
Web Kit inspector graph
that you can see the huge,
green blob there of CSS.
That's what we wanted
to get rid of.
So what does
this look like?
So this is just
a really simple snippet.
and by the way, client bundle
is not just relevant to CSS.
It actually covers
all the static resources
in your application.
If you have static text
that you're using as data,
you can actually include that
in a client bundle.
You can add PDFs
as download--
pretty much anything
that's static.
And the nice thing
about it is
as with anything
that comes out of the compiler,
it's given a nice hash name
so that you can
cache that thing
optimally.
But to focus on the CSS
for a minute,
you see here we have
a really simple example.
We declare a couple of images,
giving it an attribute,
pointing at
a particular resource
that it'll find on disk.
And then the last one
we declare a CSS resource,
and we point it
to a CSS file.
Now if you look at
the CSS file,
it has a few extra things
in it.
The first thing
you'll notice is that
there's actually
an "if statement"
that is using
a deferred binding property.
In this case,
the browser.
so we can actually
write "if statements"
around particular
user agents.
The second thing
is that there's this sprite,
so rather than
having image bundles,
which previously couldn't
take on these images
that were down in CSS,
we now have sprites
in the CSS which can handle
both the images
that you're gonna use
in the Java code
directly,
and the images that
you're going to use in CSS
altogether.
And it can bundle
them all together.
So once you have
your CSS bundled,
what does that unlock?
So the first thing is
the CSS associated with
the application,
not only can it
be made smaller,
but the download for the CSS
can actually be eliminated.
Because you can now take
the string resource
that is the CSS and you can
actually move it directly
in the compiled code.
So you've gotten rid of
the download for the CSS
altogether.
The other thing is--
Something that's very important
to GWT developers, obviously,
is that if you have
a missing resource,
it will tell you.
So that little error icon
that you have on
the error dialogue
that you didn't
think to test,
that happens to be in
the wrong place
or misnamed the disk,
you actually find that out
in compile time.
The other thing is
doing this, you're able to--
it runs through
the compiler,
so you're able to do
a lot of the dead stripping
that you get from other parts
of your code base.
Another thing is much like
the JavaScript code,
you now can
download CSS code
that is directly
targeted at your browser.
This is pretty big because
many of the CSS hacks
that people use
introduce CSS selectors
that are actually
quite expensive,
and they can actually have
another simple effect
on runtime performance.
And in fact, for images,
many of the images
can actually be
turned into data urls,
and can also be sent down
in your compiled output.
So in fact it is possible
to write an application
that is fully styled
in GWT 2.0,
and never fetch any CSS
or any images.
You only get the host page
and the compiled script.
Okay, third thing.
Third thing is this new feature,
code splitting.
So we had a lot
of people telling us,
"my app is getting
very large and I have--
"I don't really put much
on the screen when I start.
"What I would really love to do
is just load just what I need
"for the first screen,
"and then I want to load
the rest of the app
later when I need it."
And we thought
that was a good model.
But, you know, we had this
monolithic compilation,
which we were getting
a lot of good impact out of,
and we really wanted
to keep that in place.
So we found something
that actually satisfies
both camps here.
Now let me start by showing you
the effect we get out of it.
So the big, red bar
you see up here
is just a really
simple representation
of how long it takes
to load our showcase example
over a very slow
connection.
We're actually using
a proxy here
to simulate
a slow connection in GWT 1.6.
So in this case, the app
weighs in at about 285 k.
It's about 19 seconds
to load the application.
Now one of the first things
we did, of course,
when we got
code splitting working
is we went and we updated
showcase.
Now updating showcase,
as I'll show you,
was pretty simple.
We actually didn't
change anything
logically
in the application.
In fact, we just turned
a number of synchronous calls
into asynchronous calls,
and we tested it.
And here's what we got.
So the split version,
the initial download,
shrank by about 40%.
The load time
But the really
cool thing here is that
even in just trying to get
the data to present to you,
I did the initial download,
and clicked on the first link,
and got the second fragment
before the original version
would have even
finished loading.
So I think
that's a testament
to how effective
this technique actually is.
So what does it actually
look like to do this?
It's really straightforward.
Obviously you have to load code,
so we want to--
any time when you need to load
something from the server,
we actually want that
to be asynchronous
for a number
of good reasons.
It is the right thing
to do in the browser.
So we turn this
into an asynchronous call.
You give it a call back.
Previously, you would've called
here openSettingsView,
now you just wrap it
in asynchronous callback.
This code is now
being split by the compiler.
Now what does it mean
to be split?
Well, it's actually
pretty cool.
It takes everything that is
inside of that callback,
and it treats that
as sort of a code island.
And it analyzes
the actual dependencies,
looking at what
you would need
to run that little
island of code,
given what you've
already previously loaded
by all the other
split points you've hit.
So it actually generates
a lot of little code fragments
that are specifically
tailored
to where you're at
in the application.
So this is a really
cool technique.
And, you know,
as you'll see throughout
this conference,
we have a lot
of internal users
who are using this
to great effect.
And in fact, if you want
some good patterns
on how to use this,
you should see Ray Ryan's
talk.
Okay.
The fourth thing
is that GWT
interoperates
with JavaScript at no cost.
So the classic example
of this is our DOM library.
So we did have a lot of people
who wanted to write in Java,
but what they really wanted to
do was they understood the DOM,
they knew how to write against
all the existing DOM APIs,
they really just wanted a way
to use both of them together.
So in GWT 1.5,
we created this.
We created a DOM library
that allows you to basically
write what you would
write in JavaScript,
except it's all type-safe,
and of course,
given the fact
that you have types,
and the GWT compiler
can see all the types,
you actually get
all the optimizations
that are generally available
to all the rest of
your Java code.
Now usually when
you do language interop,
you end up with these wrapper
objects for various reasons.
And so the real magic here
is that in GWT,
you actually can operate
directly on a JavaScript object.
And in fact, this is what
the DOM libraries use.
but it's not something
that we withhold from ourselves.
You can actually use it
in your own code.
One of the classic
examples is JSON.
So say you need to handle that
JSON object listed at the top,
in your client code, you get
back a JavaScript object.
Now, I can cast that JavaScript
object to a person,
and I can use that.
What's actually
happening here
is that I've declared
a Java object,
and I've basically said,
"Look, compiler,
I promise that
this Java object
will represent some object
at runtime, and I want
you to just overlay it.
Just completely
overlay the type.
So it's actually
a strongly-typed Java object
that overlays a completely
untyped object at runtime.
So this is really nice
'cause it unlocks opportunities
like you saw
with the DOM libraries,
and it also unlocks
the ability
to handle JSON
very efficiently.
In fact, you can sort of
decide how efficiently
you want to handle JSON
by how paranoid you want to be
in checking whether
properties exist.
We typically just return
the properties directly.
And at runtime,
of course,
you get just property
accesses,
not calls to wrappers,
and not methods.
And of course this
is actually, you know,
available through
the inliner,
so all this gets
inlined as well.
Okay, so that's
four things GWT does for you.
But like I said,
I wanted to give you
four things you should
do for yourself
when you're creating
your GWT apps
to make them
as performant as possible.
The first thing,
and it's probably
the biggest issue we diagnose,
is that it makes sense
that you would use widgets
as the basic building blocks
of your applications,
but when you start
to get larger apps,
it doesn't necessarily fit
that you would want
everything on the screen
to be a widget.
It turns out
that because GWT
does a great job
of bookkeeping
to try to make sure you don't
introduce memory leaks.
That can actually add--
When you get a huge
widget hierarchy,
that can actually
add a little bit
to the time it requires to
build up and tear down your UI.
In fact, the two common misuses
of widgets that I'd highlight
are a lot of people
use a lot of nested widgets
for layout.
This is, in fact,
something that we may have
accidentally encouraged
by the introduction
of vertical
and horizontal panel,
but when you get
to very large apps,
that can be a bit
of a problem.
The second thing is
is that when you have widgets
that contain children,
you actually don't--
There are techniques
to avoid
having each of those children
be a widget themselves.
Because in most cases
they just need to handle events,
and there's
a way to do that.
Now I'll show you two easy
workarounds for both of these.
But first, let's handle
the general question,
which is, "How do I decide
if I need a widget?"
So it's actually
really easy.
The whole core of widgets
are about event handling.
So if you have a thing
on the screen
that doesn't actually
need to receive an event,
you actually
don't need a widget.
As I'll show you, there are
some alternatives there.
Now, even if you do
need to receive events,
there's actually some cases
where you can allow
a widget higher up
in the hierarchy
to receive those events
on your behalf,
and delegate back to you,
or delegate to a piece of code
that handles
those events for you.
And I'll show you
an example of that.
And then if you're satisfied,
both of these
are quite mature.
Sure, this is probably a case
where you need a widget.
Now the thing I said about
a widget that has
child widgets,
that's really important
if you have a widget
that has an unbounded
set of child widgets.
And I'm thinking
about a tree here.
If you have a tree,
you really have to be careful
about putting widgets
inside of a tree.
Just because you
don't often know.
Especially if that tree is
data-driven, you don't often
know how large
it's gonna grow.
And building up an unbounded
set of child widgets
at runtime when you
don't know how long it is.
That's effectively
saying,
"I don't know how long
it takes my app to load."
But I'll show you
a way around that.
So the first thing.
I'd mentioned the first
common mistake
was you use a lot of nested
widgets to do layout.
It turns out there's
a really simple technique.
There are a lot of techniques
to get around this,
but one of the ones
that I try to use here
is just simply
using an HTML panel.
Use an HTML panel,
you create the--
you basically put
the HTML in there
you need
to do your layout,
and then strategically
inside of here,
you actually put
an I.D. for where
you want to embed
another widget.
Now, if you look
at an HTML panel,
there's an overload
for the add method
that actually takes
one of these I.D.s.
So you're able
to just slip your widget
into this DOM structure
that you've created.
Now the other big thing
about using this technique
is instead of
building up the DOM
using document.createElement,
it actually uses
inner HTML,
which, in most cases,
and in some cases can be
considerably faster,
it turns out that
when you use inner HTML,
you actually skip
an entire step.
When you use
DOM.createElement,
what in fact you're doing
is you're saying,
"create me
an element,
"but also give me an API wrapper
in the JavaScript engine
'cause I'm gonna need
to do things to it."
When you pass something
to the parser,
it goes in the HTML tokenizer,
it creates DOM elements.
There's no need for it
to expose any of those.
The JavaScript engine--
as a result,
you actually reduce the number
of objects you create
when you do it this way.
So that's another big advantage
of this technique.
Now I promised a workaround
for the second misuse.
And that is you have this
widget, and it has children,
and you might be
inclined to say, well--
and imagine this widget--
I have a very simple panel
in this case,
and it needs a header
and a body.
And in each of this
header and the body
I need to be able
to click on it.
Now, I might be
inclined to just
create child widgets
underneath here,
and then handle events directly
in those child widgets,
but it's really
unnecessary here,
and in fact that
would just cause
a little bit more work
I would have to do
'cause I would have to build up
these additional widgets.
So instead,
I use something
that is inherent in the browser,
and that's event bubbling.
So if I click on an element
in the DOM tree,
the events that receive
actually traverse back up
to its parent nodes,
and you can use this,
in fact, in GWT widget,
so in this case,
I created a click ender,
but I created it
on my widget,
which is intended to be
the parent widget here.
And I can actually--
when I receive the onClick,
I actually get
something that tells me
what the target
of that click was,
and then I can use that
information to then decide
which of these sub elements
was actually clicked on,
and then I can
delegate appropriately
to run the appropriate code
for that click handler.
All without--avoiding creating
these two extra widgets.
Now this is such
a common problem
that we have a lot of people
asking us about it.
They say it's taking too long
for an app to load.
It happened enough
that we created a little tool
called
InspectorWidget.
And all this does is it allows
you to take a live GWT app--
it's a bookmarklet--
take a live app,
you click on the bookmarklet,
and it'll allow you to traverse
the widget hierarchy
in hopes of finding
some of these cases
where you can
eliminate widgets.
So we use this
a lot of times internally,
and I decided to just throw it
up on a Google co-project.
The code is not there yet, but
I'll put it up later this week.
However,
the bookmarklet is there
if you guys
want to try it.
Okay. Second thing
you should do for yourself.
Now, when you're
writing client code,
particularly client code
that runs on the web,
there's always this
sort of trade off,
this fighting
back and forth between--
What I really want to do
is I'm writing a big app,
so I want to put all these
checks in my code.
I want to make sure,
you know, I have this method,
and I've assumed
all throughout it
that the first parameter
is not null,
and I really just
want to put a check,
but the problem is
if I put the check in there,
then it's code
I have to run.
But we're actually talking
about a set of tools again,
so with GWT
you actually have--
You can get the best
of both worlds for this.
And I actually
encourage people
to use this advantage
just to its fullest.
Recognize the fact
that you have
a time when
you're debugging the app,
recognize that
you have a time
when you're running
the app for users,
make a strong separation
between them.
Now this is actually
sort of an example of--
This is a related example
that basically points to
a pattern
that we've all sort of
used from the Java world.
But it's not really
applicable for programming
for a client
that runs on the Web.
How likely is it that
you have a user
who's gonna do something
about your index
out of bounds exception?
Probably not.
What you really want to know
is that something happened.
You don't actually
want to give them
the string that's
involved here.
So this is
usually an error
that you actually
want to catch a debug time.
You actually
don't want to know
that it was exactly
an index out of bounds exception
when the user's running it.
So what we advise instead
of throwing exceptions,
in many cases,
is that you actually
just use assertions.
So assertions are turned on
by default in hosted mode.
You can turn them on
in web mode
by passing the "-ea" flag.
And one of the things
you'll notice
is that once you
put an assert in here,
this of course disappears
in a release build.
And again, this is code
you don't have to run.
Plus this method
which previously probably
could not have been inlined
is now available to the inliner.
So this doesn't apply
everywhere, of course.
You have to
use discretion,
but you should be
aware of the separation
between doing debugs,
doing release.
In fact, any time
I create a new application,
the first thing I do is I go in
and I create two modules.
I create the debug module,
and I create the release module.
The debug module I use deferred
binding to its fullest
to try to create
a bunch of tools
that will help me to keep tabs
on how fast the app is.
I particularly use it
for performance-related things.
And, you know,
straightforward way to do this.
I defined a deferred
binding property
in this case
called app.config.
It has both
release and debug.
And you can see I continue
to find some properties here
to have
different things
when I'm in debug mode
versus release mode,
and I'm careful that the
implementations for release mode
are just empty
implementations.
So, you know,
whenever the compiler
tries to build
the release build,
it just sees empty
implementations of methods,
which it just gets rid of.
And then of course
I create the debug module,
which just turns
all this stuff on.
Now, just to give you
a little example
of some things
that we've used it for...
So debug consoles are,
of course, one of these.
Writing to Firebug console
is another thing.
Even little notifications of
when things are taking too long.
Now these are really important
because if you don't actually
address performance problems
on a day-to-day basis,
it often gets very hard
to track them down
if you wait to the end.
It's certainly easier
to find a performance problem
when you know it's
in one of two commits
than it is
when you know that
it's in one of the last
three months' commits.
So we use this
to great effect,
and I would advise this
as well that you go ahead
and very early get set up
with a debug mode
and a release mode,
and use that
to its fullest.
Okay, so the third thing
you should do
is what I call
avoid forcing layout.
So this is a little graph
you're looking at.
I wanted to do
a little experiment
and I felt it
would be interesting.
You guys are probably aware
of some DOM properties--
offsetLeft, offsetTop,
offsetHeight, offsetWidth--
these are all things
in a DOM API.
What they're asking for
are certain measurements
about a particular
DOM element.
So I wanted to take
a highly optimized application--
in this case,
Google Calendar.
I knew that these guys
had been very careful
in the way they
wrote this application.
And I wanted to look at
every time offsetHeight
was called.
And then I wanted to see
how long it took each time.
Well, it called it 18 times
in the time that I ran the app,
you know, I basically opened
a few very large calendars,
closed them...
And among those 18, the range
was from 1/2 a millisecond
to 85 milliseconds.
Now you remember
I started with some times
that I thought
were important,
and if you're considering
this 85 milliseconds.
I mean, certainly when
we did that little demo,
we were sluggish
by 50 milliseconds,
so I've just blown
my entire time required
to remain interactive
on one property access.
So it's really hard
to write against this
'cause you oftentimes
don't know
how long a particular call
is going to take.
So I'll give you some simple
techniques around this,
but first,
let's answer the question.
Why does it do this?
Why does it take
an unbearable amount of time
to call a piece
of the DOM API?
So this is a screenshot
from an internal tool
that my team works on,
and this should
answer the question.
So when you call
offsetHeight,
even though it looks
like a property access,
it's not actually
a property access.
You're actually running
the layout engine
whenever you do this.
And in fact, you know,
in this case,
it's ten milliseconds
to call offsetHeight.
We spend about
three milliseconds
doing style
recalculations for CSS,
And then we spent
the rest of the time
actually doing layout,
traversing the render tree
to get the--
to figure out what
the size of everything is.
Because the browser may not
know at that time
what offsetHeight is, so it
has to go in and compute it.
So some techniques
to avoid this.
Some techniques to make sure
that, you know,
really these
techniques are about--
Well, the top technique
is about avoiding it altogether.
To the extent that you can,
try to actually use CSS alone.
We refer to this
as imperative layout.
So you use this--
try to use the things
that are available in CSS
so you don't ever
have to run the CSS code
to try to ask for
one of these measurements
to accidentally
slow down your app.
So anywhere you can,
try to stay in CSS.
If you do have to access
some of these properties,
the order becomes
very important.
It turns out that
many of the browsers
are actually quite lazy.
You do something
that invalidates
some style
in part of the DOM,
it won't actually
update the style
until you ask
for the property.
As a result, many cases
it's actually better
to avoid interleaving things
that will invalidate the style.
So here's a really
simple example.
So say I have two widgets.
If I do this order
where I take widgetA,
I set the StyleName,
which sets the class name
under the hood,
which invalidates
the style,
and then I immediately
call getAbsoluteLeft.
Well, that's gonna
cause my layout to update.
Well, then if I turn around
and set the StyleName again,
setting the class name,
invalidating the style,
and then I call
AbsoluteLeft again,
well, I've just caused
two of those long--
in this case,
probably offset left--
I've caused two of those
long calls to happen,
where if I had
just arranged it
where I invalidated
the style twice up front,
and then asked
for getAbsoluteLeft
later together,
then I would've
done much better,
and then I probably
would've only gotten
one long property access
instead of two.
So unfortunately,
these things are often
extremely hard to spot.
This is actually a hole
in the developer's story.
We're actually
working on some tools.
I hope we can actually
get those out at some point.
Okay, so the final thing.
The final thing I'm gonna
talk about is RPC-related.
Now I like to make
the joke a lot of times
that some people mistakenly
thought the "R" in RPC
stood for "replication."
GWT RPC is kind of cool
in that it can handle
arbitrary object graphs.
But the truth is you actually
don't really need that a lot.
Most of the time
you really want
to just send over exactly
what's on the screen,
and people don't really look
at large, hierarchical graphs
in a single view.
I mean, we usually
lead something
that could be made lazy
so that you can view these.
And in fact we've
sometimes seen apps
where the application start time
was completely dominated
by deserializing data.
They were moving over
so much data
that it was actually
just the time it takes
to get it off the RPC payload
and turned into Java objects
was actually dominating
the app startup.
So try to avoid that.
Instead, return only
what is visible to the user.
Actually, tailor your RPC
services to only give the things
that are gonna be
on the screen.
I have a really simple
example
to demonstrate a choice here.
So imagine
that we have this--
Imagine we have an application
that has articles.
Articles, as you might imagine,
consist of a title,
a date they were
published on,
and then some
relatively large content.
Right, this is maybe the entire
contents of a blog article.
So I could design
my RPC objects like this,
I mean, this is the most
straightforward way.
I would just create all those
things inside of the object,
I would create
one remote service interface,
and I would just return
a list of articles,
and I would display them.
But more than likely,
I'm gonna have this list
of articles
that's gonna consist
of just the date and the title,
and not the content.
Well, if I design
it this way,
obviously I'm sending over
a lot of unnecessary baggage
in that first RPC request.
I'm actually sending over
the content.
Now it is true that I may
need the content later,
however it is also true
that I don't need it right now,
and it is also true
that users
are unlikely to click
on all these articles,
and therefore
they don't need
the content
for every one of them.
So instead, you know,
a better approach here
would be to--and there are
a number of ways to do this.
In fact, I'll plug
Ray Ryan's talk again.
He has some great ways
to do this.
In fact, once you start
doing this there are
other concerns that come up
that I'll mention.
So instead of actually
moving the content,
let's just relieve
the content out of payload.
And we'll add another method
to get the content
asynchronously.
So now we can get
exactly what we want
for the list of articles,
and the content is available
at another asynchronous
callback
at any time we need it.
Now, like I said,
that opens up
all sorts of questions
about caching.
There are great ways
to do that.
You can create objects to hide
all the stuff inside of,
encapsulate it nicely,
and these sort
of techniques work quite well
architecting
your application.
All right, so I may have been
going a little fast,
but that's it,
that's it.
I'm gonna take
questions after this,
but first remind you the four
things GWT does for you.
Produces fast
JavaScript code.
Loads your non-code
resources quickly.
Splits your code elegantly
with the new code splitter.
Interoperates
with JavaScript at no cost.
By the way, if you want to see--
plug another talk--
Ray Cromwell has a really nice
talk about a library--
he's been working
on GWT query--
that makes really
bizarre and cool use
out of the overlay types
that I mentioned earlier.
And then four things
you should do for yourself.
Avoid unnecessary widgets.
Try to keep your widget
hierarchies as slim as possible.
Use debug builds
effectively.
Go ahead and set up those debug
versus release early,
and use them
to great effect.
And share the tools
if you come up with really good
tools for debug mode.
And finally,
avoid forcing layout.
I showed you some tricks
for doing that.
And fetch only what
you want to show in RPC.
If you missed the link
to InspectorWidget, it's there.
And so feel free
to use that as you wish.
And I'm happy
to take questions.
I think we still have
a lot of time left, actually.
[applause]
If you have questions,
please go to the mic,
because the last time I tried
to repeat someone's question
it was terrible.
I got it all wrong.
audience member:
Hi, there. Thanks.
With the ability
to bundle code-like images,
or I recently learned even
CSS code and various things,
can you bundle JavaScript code
in there as well?
Norton:
You could, actually.
The trick is--
Yeah, yeah, actually you could
bundle it as a text resource,
you would just have to eval it,
would be the trick.
Yeah, but that
would work.
audience member: You talked
about avoiding nesting widgets
by using HTML panel
and using I.D.s,
but those I.D.s
are all
in the same global shared
namespace, right?
Norton: Yes.
audience member: So if you've
got a pretty complex HTML layout
with a lot of I.D.s,
and then you got a dynamically
generated tool
with some function that makes
them unique and stick them in,
it can get kind of
messy, maybe,
with a lot of pluses
between your strings,
and it just looks ugly.
Is there any tricks or patterns
to clean that up?
Norton: I mean, so there are
a couple answers to that.
When you do
that technique,
yes, you have to be careful
about your names.
They have to be
globally unique.
So you do have to pay
attention to that.
I mean, you can actually
remove I.D.s if you want.
That actually works.
That's not quite
as elegant as you'd like.
audience member:
You mean remove I.D.s?
Norton:
Once you actually create
an HTML panel
with the I.D.s set,
and then you can actually
remove those I.D.s
once you have the widgets
attached to 'em.
That actually works,
but you have to be
really careful with it,
'cause it can--
subtle bugs can creep in
if you miss getting
rid of an I.D.
One of the things
is that once--
If you were here
for Bruce's talk,
I think a discussion
about UI Binder came up.
So what people once
knew as declarative UI,
which was sort of
an XML templating language,
which basically does
the HTML panel trick for you
just by declaring
a template.
Once that's available,
it takes care of
a lot of those concerns.
Sometimes you can
actually--
If you just have
a ton of I.D.s,
sometimes you can actually
switch it on its head,
and you can--
instead of doing
inner HTML,
you can sort of
create the elements
using
document.createElement.,
and create a widget
that holds all these.
But usually you just try to be
careful with the names.
It's sort of a balancing act.
Do you have something?
audience member:
[indistinct]
Norton: Oh, yes.
Oh, yes, that's right.
There is actually a method
for generating I.D.s
in an HTML panel too,
and to the extent
that you can use that.
That's really
helpful as well.
audience member: Thanks.
another audience member:
Just a question about
the fetch
what you can show with RPC.
Norton:
What's that?
audience member: Fetch only
what you can show with RPC.
So let's say you have one page,
and there's, like,
two pages that they're
potentially going to access.
So now if we only
fetch the first page,
then all of a sudden
we're probably stuck
with the one second
response time
for them going
to the next page.
So I just wonder if there's
any balance in that,
especially Web 2.0
applications
that want to appear more like
desktop applications.
Norton: Yeah,
so if you switch from--
If you actually do
a full-page refresh,
then yeah, you have to
take it on.
It turns out
that since you're actually
just sending
it out with RPC,
a lot of times you can actually
send a good bit of the data
if you mean by switching pages
you're actually
just getting the next payload
and updating it.
Now, another thing
you could do is...
particularly if you're
on an application
where your use patterns
are someone loads it up,
they spend some time
reading
or, you know,
using the page,
and then they later go to--
they later get more data,
then you can actually load
during idle time
if you're careful.
Now, the one trick
there is that--
or the one risk is that
you begin loading something
just when they
change something
in a completely
different direction,
but if you have fairly--
if you have good user patterns,
then, you know,
you track those user patterns,
sometimes you can actually
get the content you needed
for the highly probable
next action
in the idle time.
audience member:
In your benchmarking,
how do you get
accurate timing
for Windows Internet
Explorer?
I understand
the time resolution
is, like, 15 milliseconds
on Windows.
Norton: We're--
so you can probably tell
from some of the tools
we're instrumenting pretty
deeply into the browser,
so for instance,
for Internet Explorer,
we're actually getting
low-level calls
in calling
the multimedia timers.
So we're getting nice,
good timing on those.
That's part
of the reason why--
that's part of the reason
why I didn't show
a lot of those things running
everywhere, because, you know,
you have to get
the instrumentation in place.
Yeah.
audience member:
I have a crazy question for you.
I've been wondering
for a long time
why someone
doesn't do this,
and you guys have the biggest
opportunity to actually do it,
which is suppose someone
writes their whole app in GWT,
so it's written
basically in Java,
and then the browser, you know,
that's maybe, say, Chrome,
and the user agent
is one of the fields of HTTP,
so Chrome browser talks to a
back-end that's running in GWT,
and Chrome browser says,
"hey, I need a web page,
[whispers]
but psst, we're Google, okay?"
And the GWT site says,
"I hear you want a web page,
[whispers]
but hey, we're Google too."
And, you know,
and it says,
"Don't tell anybody,
but look.
"Instead of
all that Web crap,
here's the byte codes
for the Java."
And just send that over,
and the Chrome browser says,
"Okay, I'll just
run that instead."
Get rid of the whole browser,
and we have a world
where people go to web pages
and they are apps.
Norton: Right.
audience member:
I'm sure I'm not
the first person
to think of this,
but it almost seems
possible now, actually.
Could you comment?
Norton: It does seem possible.
We've talked a lot about it.
It's unclear what the balancing
act is there between--
I mean, you know,
so you take VMs, I mean,
the V8 guys are doing
a pretty good job with that VM,
so it's possible.
I don't know.
Maybe it'll happen.
Just not sure.
I mean, certainly we've had
discussions about it,
and we think
it's pretty cool too,
but I don't know.
I don't know that
I can comment too much.
I just don't--
I think it's a cool world.
audience member: Do you think
it would really be a win?
'Cause it would defeat
a few other things.
You'd have to have,
you know--
You no longer
have generic tools
that can, say,
look at your HTML
and, say, feed it to
a search engine
with a bunch of keywords.
You wouldn't be able
to display it to people
who can't read
by reading it to them
or letting them search,
you know.
So you'd have to
implement all that too.
Norton:
Yeah, and it'd take
a lot of consideration
from a user standpoint too.
Whether JVMs are installed
and whatnot.
I guess it could be
baked in, but...
audience member:
Oh, I see. Okay, sure.
another audience member: Sort of
a related question to that,
kind of.
But you have done a lot of
low-level instrumentation
on browsers like
you talked about
and the screenshots
you showed.
And one of the things
I know, Kelly, you found
is that it's not actually
the JavaScript code
that's necessarily
limiting anymore,
it's actually the other stuff,
like all the DOM, you know,
and CSS manipulation
and layout and so on.
So as you've looked at it,
and I've seen
you personally
look at these things
very deeply,
what are the things
that surprised you the most?
The sort of things
that are done
all the time
in the Web that,
when you do it a lot,
have wildly varying behavior
in different browsers,
or things that seemed innocuous
that had really bad effects.
Norton: Actually there's a
really good one, and that is--
It is surprising.
So I showed you offsetHeight
taking a long time.
It turns out that
the time--
Not only is it the time
to take a variable
across the state
your DOM in,
that number
is actually affected
quite a bit by the CSS styles
that are active.
And in fact, you can actually
see that number climb up
if you start to introduce
more descendant selectors.
Descendant selectors
are pretty expensive
because effectively how
they work in many browsers
is they go and find
the thing you declare
on the far
right-hand side first,
and then they have to walk up
to see if they can satisfy--
see if they can satisfy
the selector as it goes up.
Now there are certain
descendant selectors
like the universal
selector,
which basically says
"match everything."
If you think about
what that means,
that means that okay,
what you're telling the browser
is take every element.
Now walk up the tree,
and tell me
if it satisfies
the selector.
Since those styles
have to be taken into account
in order to answer things
like offsetHeight,
you actually see that they do
have an effect on these times.
That was actually
one of the surprising things.
And the other surprising thing
is it tends to affect,
counter-intuitively,
some DOM calls
that you wouldn't even
have thought it would affect.
Like we see calls
to cloneNode go up
because of CSS
style matching.
We're not quite sure
why in some browsers
they actually apply styles
whenever you do a cloneNode
when it's not attached
to the DOM yet,
but we actually see
the times for that go up.
So many things like that
have been surprising.
Yeah, I mean, I think
that's the biggest thing.
I can't think
of anything else.
Yeah, there's a lot of
surprisingly good data
inside there.
Oh, actually there's
another interesting one,
and that is--
I showed you the example
with invalidating styles
and sort of
flip-flopping.
Well, it turns out on--
It turns out that
we found some evidence
on Internet Explorer.
For tables, there's actually
a table cache,
a table layout cache,
and if you set className,
you invalidate
the table layout cache.
If you're just trying
to update
a background in that table,
and you just
setStyle.background,
you actually don't invalidate
the table layout cache.
So there's some
interesting stuff
in the instrumentation
we're doing.
And that example, for instance,
would be counter-intuitive
and would actually
go against some device
that has been, you know,
industry standard
that you would
set class names
to avoid causing so many
reflows in browsers.
That would actually be
a device that was--
that ran counter to that, so.
audience member: Related to
avoiding unnecessary widgets--
To me that--just to start
implementing that
seems like it's gonna
make more and more code
that's hard to maintain
because you're
dumping a lot of your
object orient into text.
Why aren't y--
but the r--
The question
I came up with was
why aren't you guys
creating more widgets
that implement
some of this stuff
so you could give
a broader set of widgets
that could handle more
of these low-level things?
Norton:
So the good answer is we are.
And in fact, the UI Binder
that we talked about,
which is sort of
the declarative markup,
is intended
for exactly that.
We had the same
observation.
We're like, okay,
it's kind of distressing
that in order
to make things faster,
having to move things
into strings--
we hate moving things
into strings.
It runs against
everything in our core--
and so that's the reason
why we're trying
to create these other tools
that are in fact checked,
and will, you know,
do the right thing at runtime.
So that stuff is coming,
and it is definitely
on our minds.
So right now, if you have to
do these things by hand,
you know, we tend to
do them carefully,
and we, you know,
tend to use,
a lot of times, generators.
GWT generators, which may be
a foreign concept.
If it is, there's information
on the website,
but that's also a good way
to handle a lot of these things.
An advanced method,
but it's available.
Any other questions?
All right,
thank you guys.
[applause]